[Musique]
bonsoir a tous un grand plaisir d'être
ce soir avec des passionnés des
passionnés de tous les sujets dont nous
allons parler ce soir avec une relation
plus ou moins proche à l'amour et puis
la passion également de tous les
conférenciers qui m'ont précédé j'ai eu
beaucoup de plaisir à les entendre et la
passion également de ceux qui vont
suivre dans un petit moment
ravi d'être en tout cas avec vous un
petit peu plus de monde que ce matin
quand on a fait les répétitions et c'est
amusant de voir que en fait les places
pour cette soirée se sont vendus encore
plus vite que le nombre de minutes que
nous avons à disposition je rate le
chrono tourne déjà donc on va pas perdre
de temps cette passion pour les cloches
comment est ce qu'elle a pu naître chez
toi américains c'est la question qu'on
me pose très souvent parce que vous me
connaissez peut-être si vous avez déjà
eu l'occasion d'écouter radio fribourg
un j'aime bien faire du bruit le matin
la radio tous les matins entre 6h et 10h
et le week-end mais voilà quand je ne
suis pas à l'antenne moi je fais du
bruit avec mes cloche là pour une petite
diapositives d'introduction j'en ai
sélectionné une petite dizaine de ces de
ces photos durant lesquels je vais vous
narrer un peu comment est née cette
passion et comment je la vis encore
aujourd'hui
là on voit par exemple avec deux cloches
qui était dans le clocher du temple de
dayan dans le canton de vaud qui ont été
méchamment endommagée ce qu'au lieu de
se balancer ya eu des problèmes de
moteur elles sont parties en tournant
elles se sont heurtées les unes les
autres on aurait pu les envoyer à la
casse à la place de sagna des artisans
passionnés et passionnants qu'on appelle
des campani ce qu'ils ont réparé
aujourd'hui ces cloches sont donc comme
neuf
cette passion pour les cloches elle m'a
pris quand j'étais tout petit je l' ai
vécu grâce à mes parents à mon père qui
m'a toujours beaucoup encouragé dans
cette passion seulement quand je serai à
l'arrivée à l'âge de l'adolescence vous
savez comment sont les ados et les
cloches
qu'est ce qui te plaît là dedans la
musique le foot c'est tellement mieux
ah bah finalement jeté un peu mise en
veilleuse cette passion c'est comme ça
qu'est née ma seconde passion qui est
devenu aujourd'hui mon métier c'est
laisser la radio et c'est seulement il
ya je dirais une petite quinzaine une
petite vingtaine d'années où est né ce
formidable média qu'on appelle internet
sur lequel on crache très souvent mais
qui permet quand même deux fois de
mettre des gens en réseau qui ont la
même passion surtout quand la passion
n'est pas très
pas très répandu et aujourd'hui je me
suis dit c'est un beau un bon groupe
d'amis avec lesquels je fais très
souvent des découvertes en voyage à
l'étranger on s'invite les uns les
autres et maintenant la passion est
belle comme elle n'a jamais été sur la
passion elle est véritablement né ici je
crois là vous avez un édifice
relativement moderne c'est le temple de
fontenay à yverdon les bains
j'ai grandi dans ce quartier et mes
parents me raconte encore aujourd'hui
moi j'ai un peu oublié tout ça parce que
j'ai je devoir trop quatrième on dirait
quand on promener dans ton quant à
poussette devant cette église les
cloches se met à sonner plutôt que de
pleurer parce que c'est quand même assez
sonore
toi tu avais l'air très intéressé tu
tendait la main comme pour les attraper
un peu comme ces jouets éducatifs convoi
des fois dans les pubs à la télé que les
parents connaissent certainement des des
parents qui ont dû acheter ça à leurs
enfants
et voilà ça a été peut-être le
déclencheur je pense que sept
déclencheurs quand j'étais tout petit et
c'est amusant de constater que cette
église en fait on aime ou on aime pas l
architecture moderne c'est quand même
assez aberrant au niveau de sa
conception par rapport à l'acoustique
parce que vous avez trois cloches qui
sont dans un clocher comme ça il n'y a
pas vraiment de caisse de résonance si
on veut que l'acoustique soit soit
parfaite
et en plus vous voyez la claque c'est en
fait ce qu'on appelle le parvis se fait
juste à côté des cloches quand ça sonne
on a environ 100 db c'est un peu plus
que ce qui est autorisé aujourd'hui dans
l'est dans les concerts dans les
discothèques en vous avez les fidèles la
plupart du temps relativement âgées qui
se bouche les oreilles c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'il ya de moins en moins de
gens qui vont à l'église aujourd'hui
mais voilà je voulais quand même signalé
çà c'était c'était une petite anecdote
comme ça on va dire technique au passage
pour montrer que c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure construction qui a été fait
pour que ces cloches sonnent bien
aujourd'hui mais c'est quand même un
clocher on va dire didactique qui m'a
permis de lancer ma passion qui est
toujours là aujourd'hui et je tenais à
la remercier même si elle est partie
depuis une concierge unsa christine
absolument formidable qui s'appelle
marie louise massenet et qui a qui a
oeuvré pendant
50 ans cinquante ans elle était
concierge sacristine de ceux de ce
temple à yverdon et puis ça a été la
première à me faire confiance à me
donner les clés à l'époque la sacristie
et c'est moi j'étais tout fier j'allais
appeler sur les boutons pour démarrer
les trois cloches pour les police o6
donc ça c'était vraiment mon premier
contact avec les cloches est le deuxième
contact parmi tant d'autres cd celui ci
toujours dans le nord vaudois cette
belle région qui m'a vu naître
c'est le temple de boom et l'a donc vous
pouvez le constater on a un vrai clocher
donc c'est la première fois que je
montais des marches d'escalier et c'est
la première fois que je me retrouvais
face à un bourdon parce que l'on ne voit
peut-être pas sur la photo mais la
cloche que nous avons à gauche elle pèse
un peu plus de trois tonnes je pense
quand je suis monté dans ce clocher la
première fois je devais pesé j'étais
moins lourde que maintenant je vais
poser à peu près au web 20 à 30 kg on
vous laisse imaginer un petit gosse qui
monte en face de ceux qui se retrouvent
face à un monstre de bronze comme ça je
me rappelle j'étais à la fois fasciné
parce que je les voyais pour la première
fois de si près en même temps j'avais
peur j'ai fait des cauchemars après pour
donner nuits entières ou j'imaginais que
j'étais en face de cette cloche et elle
commence à se balancer que moi fallait
que je me sauve pour ne pas être écrasés
contre les murs ou projetée à travers
les baies du clocher en bas voilà c'est
des petits souvenirs d'enfance comme ça
qu'ils reviennent
et ça je le dois à mon papa qu'une fois
ma effet la surprise
il avait pris contact avec le sacristain
et la liesse serait possible d'avoir les
clés passe confie son envie d'aller voir
et puis un jour on est allé ce qu'on
allait très souvent les écouter ses
cloches et puis un jour j'ai pu monter
pour la première fois dans ce clocher
voilà ça c'est des souvenirs d'enfance
et il a bien joué aussi remercier mon
papa qui malheureusement n'est pas là ce
soir
mais grâce à qui j'ai pu vivre
pleinement cette passion et qui m'a
toujours encouragée alors que lille
avait d'autres passions comme comme par
exemple la paléontologie ou encore
l'astronomie troisième étape de cette de
cette passion
là c'est la première fois que j'ai pu
tirer une tâche à la corde
c'est peut-être de là que m'est venue le
surnom de quasimodo quasimodo vous
connaissez un sonneur de notre dame de
paris
seule différence c'est qu'il a la bosse
dans le noble et sur le ventre mais on a
un point commun on a la bosse en bosse
des cloches voilà donc la danse est le
chai de peney huit boeufs on a une
cloche de cloche on en a un qui sont
aujourd'hui encore ce n'est à la corde
et ça devient quelque chose de plus en
plus rares on avait aussi à l'époque
quand j'étais en sang le mouvement
d'horloge que vous pouvez voir en haut à
droite de la de la diapositive qui
malheureusement aujourd'hui ne
fonctionne plus il a été remplacé par un
système électronique à l'époque on avait
l'employé communal qui montaient toutes
les semaines et qui donnaient environ
100 tours de manivelle sur les deux
poulies de l'horloge fallait avoir des
biscotos 1 c'était très très très
physique en plus il fallait monter dans
le clocher parce que horloge évidemment
n'est pas au rez-de-chaussée autrement
ce serait beaucoup trop facile et donc
cette tour était autrefois le clocher
d'une église romane qui datait du xiiie
siècle l'église qui a été démoli au
début du 19e siècle on a préféré en
construire une oeuvre un petit peu plus
loin à habib beye pour ceux qui
connaissent la région
par contre alors ça c'est une bonne
chose les deux cloches historiques
existent toujours
elles ont été coulés toutes les deux en
1477 elles ont toutes une histoire parce
que cloche ne sont pas que des objets
c'est pour ça que les apprécie peut-être
parce qu'il ya toujours des histoires et
des destins qui viennent s'entremêler
ses cloches existait avant 1470 cif en
1476 son nom à la fameuse bataille de
grand- chose qui a vu la victoire
yes des confédérés sur l'armée de
charles le téméraire et après donc on a
réquisitionné les cloches parce qu'on
avait besoin du bronze pour faire des
canons à l'époque les canons étaient en
bronze et après la bataille qui a été
gagnée on le rappelle les cloches sont
redevenus des cloches le bronze est
redevenu des cloches et on a toujours
ces deux cloches qui malheureusement
aujourd'hui sonne très rarement ce qu'à
l'époque quand j'étais monté là bas donc
c'était dans les années 1970 et que je
jeu masquer mon à jeudi jusqu'à se
passait dans les années 1970 à l'époque
et ben à ses cloches sonnaient tous les
jours à midi on avait un employé
communal qu'on a plein marguilliers qui
était chargé de tirer sur la corde
aujourd'hui malheureusement elle sonne
une à deux fois par an quand il ya des
cultes en plein air devant ce devant
cette tour de l'horloge
ça c'est une cloche qui m'a toujours
interpellé quand j'étais petit j'avais
ma famille du côté de maman qui habitait
qu'habitait soleure nous on habite à
yverdon donc à l'époque on n'est pas
l'autoroute en prenaient la route qui
longeait le pied du jura c'est très joli
il ya des bons vignoble d'ailleurs un
peu rapport à ce qui s'est dit tout à
l'heure
et cette cloche m'a toujours interpellé
je me suis dit mais c'est qu'est ce
qu'elle fait là accroché au bord de la
route en plus elle ressemble pas toutes
les cloches que j'ai vu jusqu'à présent
les autres sont en bronze elles prennent
de la patine un peu comme les statuts
que vous avez dans les jardins publics
quand les pigeons bien si on les
recouvre pas de leurs déjections et
cette loi je me disais on dirait qu'elle
est en acier qu'est ce qu'est ce que
c'est exactement j'ai appris seulement
beaucoup plus tard on a pendant une
certaine période couler des cloches en
acier plutôt que du bronze
parce que avec tous ces nombreux
conflits qu'on a eu en europe par
exemple la guerre franco-prussienne de
1870 la guerre 14-18 la guerre 39-45 à
l'époque ont réquisitionné à nouveau le
bronze mais non plus pour faire des
canons mais pour faire pour en extraire
le cuivre qui allait par la suite
devenir des douilles pour les cartouches
et les obus donc un fabricant quelques
fabricants un peu plus malin que les
autres se sont dit on va proposer des
cloches en acier comme ça elle au moins
ne seront pas réquisitionné en plus ça
sur un tout petit peu moins cher à
l'achat
par contre au bout de quelques années l
etat est plutôt pitoyable et puis la
résonance de l'acier est loin d'être
aussi bonne que du bronze
une fois vous passez à courtepin pendant
que l'église sonne vous en êtes vous
avez des cloches qui sont certes très
intéressante ne pas de très bonne
qualité ce sont aussi des cloches en
acier comme celle ci qui a à mon avis
bien mérité sa retraite passer à quelque
chose peut-être d'un peu plus marquant
pour ceux qui habitent en ville de
fribourg qui se promènent des fois le
soir les noctambules autour de la
cathédrale saint-nicolas nous avons une
cloche qui a été coulé je vous laisse
voir la date 1367 et cette cloche sonne
encore tous les soirs le couvre-feu à
22h15 ça fait partie inhérente vraiment
de la culture de la tradition de la
ville à l'entendre on parle de
couvre-feu on pense pas au couvre-feu
guerriers on parle de couvre-feu à
l'époque au moyen âge où les villes
étaient construites pour la plupart en
bois où un incendie forcément dans
toutes ces maisons mitoyennes aurait été
un véritable désastre malheureusement là
beaucoup de villiers à l'époque qu'ils
ont été
qui ont été détruites par des incendies
pas seulement londres désistement pour
empêcher ce genre de drame on a instauré
la sonnerie du couvre-feu et c'était
pour dire qu'il fallait vraiment et ils
mojo league étymologiquement quel mode
et le mot difficile il fallait couvrir
les solis aller éteindre tout ce qui
était foyer pour éviter justement des
incendies qui voit là bas même si
aujourd'hui ça n'a plus vraiment lieu
d'être
la tradition est heureusement des
demeurés et cette cloche sonne tous les
soirs encore à 22h15
je vous laisse imaginer pour ce qui a
changé en ville de fribourg un même la
cathédrale n'était pas la même à
l'époque les générations se sont
succédées mais la cloche est toujours là
elle a la même voix qu'à l'origine
peut-être qu'elle soit de même mieux
encore aujourd'hui parce qu'on gagne un
équipement est devenu un battant qui
permet de l'aménager le but qu'elles
continuent encore à charmer des
générations sur des siècles et des
siècles autres cathédrales pas très loin
de chez nous la cathédrale de berne
enfin cathédrale est un abus de langage
parce qu'en fait c'est plutôt une
collégiale ça n'a jamais été une
collégiale là c'était juste pour vous
montrer le plus grand bourdon que nous
avons en suisse moins chiant photo à
côté je suis tout petit piti piti alors
que owens dans un gabarit imposant mais
je vous laisse imaginer la taille d'une
cloche comme ça qui pèse 10 tonnes
presque 10 tonnes 9800 kg
c'est aussi une très belle pièce
historique a été coulé en en 1611 et
elle sonne encore toujours aujourd'hui
c'est la plus grande de suisse
le bourdon de la cathédrale de fribourg
ne fait que entre guillemets 7 tonnes en
est tout petit
la plus grande cloche envolé d'europe
dont cloche qui se balançait
véritablement vient d'être coulé pour la
cathédrale de bucarest elle pèse 26
tonnes on est encore dans le plus grand
et puis la plus grande cloche jamais
coulé au monde ne sonne plus vous avez
peut-être déjà vu des photos c'est là
que sarko le col et les déposer devant
le devant le kremlin à moscou
et elle pèse 200 tonnes voilà elle n'a
jamais pu ce n'est malheureusement pas
ce canton la sortie de la fosse canton
la démouler ya un morceau qui est tombée
aujourd'hui on a fait une chapelle
dessous c'est très très insolite douala
comme qu'on recycle tout aussi que tous
voulaient m'attarder quelques instants
sur les différentes parties de la cloche
voilà vous avez quelques termes
techniques vous a peut-être des mots je
les ai mis spécialement au gras si je
vous dis les oreilles le cerveau
l'épaule
la robe la panse la lèvre inférieure on
est vraiment dans les partis sinon de
l'habillement en tout cas de l'anatomie
humaine et on se rend compte vraiment
qu'il ya une personnification autour de
la cloche et je pense que si on a
baptisé au fil des siècles les cloches
avec des termes comme ceux ci c'est
qu'on se dit qu'il ya une une
personnification est certainement un
attachement à l'ogs a été la cloche
voilà c'était la petite partie lexical
outre les clochers que j'ai eu
l'occasion de visiter régulièrement et
dans lesquels j'apprends toujours des
choses à chacune de mes d'exploration il
ya aussi des événements comme ça qui
marque et ça c'est un événement qui m'a
beaucoup plu à settat ya un mois à peu
près on a assisté à la montée d'une
nouvelle cloche au papier en juillet et
là on a vraiment hisser cette cloche à
l'ancienne comme vous pouvez le
constater vous avez vous avez des
enfants qui tire qui tire sur une corde
qui vous avez cette cloche qui monte un
peu comme un téléphérique avec un câble
porteur qu'on peut voir et puis un câble
un câble tracteurs on n'a pas hissé à la
verticale la topographie de l'église
avec des avants toi tout autour faisait
que ce n'était malheureusement pas
possible
l'entreprise qui était chargé de monter
cette cloche la maison mes catala bros
spécialisée dans la restauration des
clochers l'entretien a opté justement
donc pour ce système de téléphérique et
on l'a fait à l'ancienne
ce sont vraiment les enfants qui ont
tiré sur la corde et à mesure qu'ils
tiraient sur la corde envoyé cette
cloche s'élever ça je pense que ça a été
un beau souvenir ça va être un beau
souvenir pour eux je me rappelle avoir
assisté à une montée de cloche comme ça
dans le canton de lucerne
il ya bien des années j'avais réussi à
décrypter un petit peu le schwyzerdütsch
et le le curé avait dit à ses enfants
vous verrez dans quelques années vous
serez des grands pères et des grands
mères vous serez au chevet de vos
petits-enfants ou le raconterait des
histoires pour qu'il s'endorme le soir
et vous leur direz as tu entends
l'angélus et ben à l'époque c'est moi
qui avaient monté cette cloche et je
pense que ces enfants ça va les marquer
encore pendants en prenant quelques
années cette cloche a été coulé par à la
fonderie cornille havard qui se trouvent
dans l'ouest de la france et c'est la
fonderie qui a coulé les nouvelles
cloches de notre dame de paris donc là
on a vraiment un bon ami gage de qualité
je l'entends du lors de ses prestations
décès et c'était vraiment une cloche qui
avait une belle voix toutes les montées
des cloches malheureusement ne se passe
pas toujours aussi bien aujourd'hui on a
vraiment les prescriptions de sécurité
le petit bonhomme que vous voyez sur
cette photo mine de rien il a failli et
se ramasser cette cloche sur la tête
tendance est véridique c'est arrivé à
regensdorf en 1915 si je dis pas de
bêtises et cette cloche était en train
de hisser haut clocher les enfants
étaient quasiment dessous et quand la
cloche est arrivé près de son lieu de
destination la corde a cassé et la
cloche s'est écrasé sur le sol les
archives de la de la paroisse de
regensdorf raconte que c'est le
sacristain qui a vu que la corde
commencé à voir des faiblesses qui s'est
jetée sur ce petit garçon qui l'a
violemment poussée c'est presque en
scénario de film et qui lui a évité de
de connaître une mort certaine
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on prend
vraiment des prescriptions de sécurité
mais à l'époque on faisait peut-être un
petit peu moins attention c'est marrant
un devoir ce petit bonhomme il ya
quelque chose d'attachant m'ont déjà là
la mode comme on habillait les enfants à
l'époque
et voilà je crois qu'il a il a vraiment
eu chaud il n'y a pas d'autres mots je
pense que ça aussi c'est quelque chose
qui a dû le remarquer pendant une bonne
partie de son existence
et puis voilà aussi un événement auquel
j'ai eu l'occasion d'assister aux deux
ou trois fois c'est véritablement là la
coulée d'une cloche c'est toujours très
impressionnant
il faut savoir que le le bain de métal
que vous avez là c'est 1200 degrés à peu
près et j'ai eu l'occasion d'assister à
une coulée notamment à la la fonderie
paccard annecy en suisse nous avons plus
qu'une seule fonderie de cloches
monumental se trouve à arreau et encore
beaucoup de fondeurs de cloches de vache
ça heureusement c'est un artisanat kate
est bien conservé mais les cloches
d'église vu qu'on fait de moins en moins
l'église est de moins en moins de
cloches forcément que des fonderies ont
dû fermer
j'avais l'occasion d'assister à la
coulée du bourdon de l'abbaye de
saint-maurice qui est une cloche de 4
tonnes alors imaginez pendant 4 à 5
minutes vous avez ce ce métal en fusion
qui coule en face de vous évidemment que
les les artisans de la fonderie les
maîtres fondeurs ont des combinaisons en
amiante autrefois c'étaient des tabliers
en cuir et puis quand vous êtes dans le
public que vous sentez vraiment ce ce
souffle d'air chaud est aujourd'hui je
garde une affection toute particulière
pour le bourdon de l'abbaye de saint
maurice en valais j'ai pu assister à ça
coulait comme j'ai dit et puis assistent
à sa coulée j'ai pu assister à ça à sa
montée cet effet par une grue
malheureusement pas par les enfants
c'est bien dommage
et puis j'ai pu appuyer sur le bouton de
commande pour la première fois que la
cloche s'est mis en branle donc
forcément chaque fois que je vais là-bas
j'ai un ami qui est carillonneur
j'assiste souvent à des concerts de
carillon la bâche ready du patrimoine là
bas cet été chaque fois c'est une cloche
qui me sait quelque chose
voilà donc andy diapositives comment est
née cette passion un peu insolite pour
les cloches j'espère que la prochaine
fois que vous passerez à côté d'un
clocher que vous entendrez ce n'est un
angélus où une messe de préférence un
événement heureux parce que des fois les
cloches et moi si les événements un peu
moins heureux de notre vie voulez vous
les considérez peut-être un petit peu
différemment que des simples objets de
bronze
et puis si vous avez envie de poursuivre
la découverte du patrimoine campanaire
fribourgeois ou ailleurs je peux vous
donner rendez vous sur mon site internet
quasimodo sonneurs de cloches - ch je
fais régulièrement des visites des
visites guidées et puis je propose
régulièrement des des reportages sur mon
site
voilà belle soirée
[Musique]